One of the world's most successful investors is Warren Buffett.
From world leaders to old ladies, everyone hangs on every word he utters.
One of his approaches is quite simple.
He says that most investors are not super-investors.
They don't differentiate between price and value.
For example, a skyrocketing stock somehow appears safe and strong,...
...but what we should remember is that risk surfaces...
...when market value equals or surpasses a company's intrinsic value.
So, the connection between risk and price can often be the opposite of what one might think.
For example, Google was hugely risky in 2007 when the market assumed its stocks would soar,...
...becoming less risky in late 2008 when the market was volatile...
...and everyone thought that investing would be suicide.
The best time to invest is when the rift between price and intrinsic value is at its widest.